وقبل ان انتقل الى مراسل العربيه في اديس
ابابا هذه صوره مباشره نقلها اليكم من
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس والتي تشهد
احتجاجات مستمره للجاليه الكرديه في باريس
هذه الاحتجاجات تاتي بعد مقتل ثلاثه من
الجاليه
الكرديه في باريس على يد مسلح قبل يومين
هذه تظاهرات جديده للاكراد تمدد بالهجوم
على مركز
اللاجئين في فرنسا همم المتظاهرون يطالبون
بمزيد من الحمايه للاكراد باعتبار كذلك
الاعتداء الذي حدث يوم الجمعه الماضي وادى
بحياه همم ثلاثه منهم عملا ارهابيا وليس
فقط مجرد اعتداء عنصري فيما ايضا نعرف بان
المجتمع به سيتم عرضه على قاضي الاستجواب
هذا اليوم تتزام كما ذكرنا هذه التظاهره
للاكراد في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس بعد
الهجوم على مركز اللاجئين الذي استهدف
ثلاثه اشخاص واصيب فيه اخرون كذلك همم
باعتبار طبعا هذا الاعتداء كما يقول هؤلاء
المتظاهرين او المتظاهرون ايضا
بانه همم
يجب المطالبه طبعا بالمزيد من الحمايه
للاكراد انه نشاهد هذه الصور ايضا كذلك
حتى التي ترفع من قبل الجاليه الكرديه في
هذه التظاهرات التي
ذكرنا بانها تستمر منذ الجمعه الماضيه
وبعد ان تم استهداف ثلاثه اكراد في مركز
همم للاجئين همم تظاهرات كنا قد تابعناها
واياكم بدات منذ الجموع الماضيه